hi guys my name is Jess McDonald it's
the 9th of April and you're watching
games but news symptoms may include an
increased awareness of video game news
and an irritation at stupid people being
stupid someone really hit the nail on
the head with that second one today
because the study's been conducted to
say that gamers get more frustrated when
the controls of the game are frustrating
I'm glad someone went all Captain
Obvious and figured that one out
according to the study from Oxford
University levels of aggression aren't
actually correlated with the violence in
games but rather the frustration of not
being able to master the controls so
it's more likely to be games that are
unreasonably difficult or unfamiliar to
the subject which evoked the angry
violent feelings about them having an
insane amount of consonants in his last
name researcher dr. Andrew preserve
Liske has also contributed we focused on
the motives of people who play
electronic games and found players have
a psychological need to come out on top
when playing if players feel thwarted by
the controls or the design of the game
they can wind up feeling aggressive he
also added that players on games without
any violent content was still feeling
pretty aggressive if they hadn't been
able to master the controls all progress
through the levels at the end of the
session that actually makes a lot of
sense I take back my mocking from
earlier let me know what you think that
borderlands pre-sequel is officially
coming as confirmed by 2k games but it
won't be moseying over to the xbox one
or ps4 it turns out the leaked
information earlier this week was pretty
damn accurate though the game is set on
Pandora's moon and you can play as water
parents and Jack's four lieutenants one
of which is claptrap himself there's a
new cryo effect so you can freeze your
foes as well as laser weaponry and oz
packs which will supply oxygen when
you're out on the moon and function as
jetpacks the game is being developed
mainly out of 2k Australia so be sure to
hit us with your apt and mildly
stereotypical predictions as to what
we'll see in the new installment and
finally the last of us is coming to ps4
and in 1080p no less the remastered
edition will be landing this summer with
all the previously released single and
multiplayer DLC as well as high res
character models textures and improved
shadows and lighting they're also
currently shooting for 60 frames per
second
according to creative director Neil
druckmann alongside all that there will
be directors commentary for all in-game
cinematics the PSN store and various
retailers have been listing the title
for 60 bucks there are also a bunch of
extra single and multiplayer mode
pre-order bonuses the details of which
you can find in our new story on games
but now let me know if you are
interested in picking this one up either
in that comment section down below or
you can let me know on my twitter where
i'm at just mcdonald those are all the
things that i want to tell you about
today but i'll have a bunch more news
tomorrow so be sure you check back with
me then